okay I've gotten a ton of requests to
talk about canceled culture so I want to
dig into it today and spend some time
talking about this if you haven't heard
of canceled culture cancel culture is a
term that's really all it is to refer to
what is essentially calling someone out
for doing something objectionable right
canceling your subscription tweeting
about it telling an advertiser not to
buy a product telling a Hollywood not to
hire a certain actor or whatever the
case may be it's a type of activism
essentially and I really want to repeat
this because I think it's important for
framing the entire conversation we
should not talk about canceled culture
as the thing that is new what is new is
that it's been named canceled culture
and it's been dubbed by some a major
problem in society and then we can
discuss whether it really is a major
problem in society or not so my starting
point for talking about canceled culture
is first to ask does this exists is this
really a thing that exists then we ask
questions like is it widespread is it
growing for some particular reason at
this point in time once we figure that
out then we can say well is it a problem
is this a bad thing and then lastly we
discuss what if anything should be done
about it right you we actually want to
go through this in the right way as
opposed to doing what some on the right
and maybe a few people on the left but
mostly on the right are saying cancel
culture has exploded among the woke left
suppression of speech but a little a
little okay we're not going to do it
that way we're actually going to go
through it so is canceled culture a real
thing yes it is sure it is it is true
that sometimes people will boycott or
try to get other people to boycott or
try to get advertisers to pull ads or
get people to unfollow someone on social
media or whatever the case may be
because there is the belief or claim
that a person has done or said something
objectionable people do things that are
perceived as objectionable all the time
different people interpret it as
objectionable
or not and then some people decide to
just go on with their day others decide
to tweet about it others decide to call
advertisers whatever it exists that is
not new 1933 may be an extreme example
the American Jewish Congress said
Germany as an entity is now anti-semitic
boycott Germany that is something which
could be called cancel culture
supposedly a starting in 1973 various
LGBT groups said Coors Brewing Company
has anti-gay hiring practices do not buy
Coors beer a scary cancel culture right
I mean that we're talking about very
similar things now later we'll get into
we don't want this person speaking at
our college we're gonna get to that okay
but the point is this is not new it's
activism that's been around for a really
long time some people like it some
people don't
their second question is it widespread
and is it more widespread today for
example well that really depends on what
you mean you'll hear people on the right
who claim to be against canceled culture
say you know the hashtag cancel whatever
was used
eleventy billion times or something
right okay well we have social media now
it's bigger than it was three years ago
it's bigger than it was six years ago
the fact that a particular hashtag was
used a bunch of times three months ago
doesn't really tell us in any empirical
way whether canceled culture has reached
epidemic proportions what I do see is
people realizing that money is at the
root of much of our economy and using
economic threats to try to do activism
may be useful and that's where ad
boycotts come from and we can have a
debate about whether that's a useful or
effective type of activism what we have
to point out is that just because
something exists and you give it a name
doesn't mean that it's any more
pervasive than it was before social
media may provide a more convenient
it means for people to say don't buy
this or don't watch that show or
whatever the case may be but just
because we now have dubbed it canceled
culture doesn't mean it's actually more
of an epidemic so to speak I'll give you
an example that many of you will
remember the regressive left remember
when that term was floating around you
had some people on the left and the
right using this term regressive left
and we did a very we did a deep dive
video about it
the left and right used the term
differently the left when they said
regressive left usually meant when when
they when they want to point to someone
who claims to be on the left but is
doing something that's not really left
so for example you might have left ISM
that is really authoritarianism but it's
being hidden as left ISM that would be
an example of the left being regressive
rather than progressive now the right
caught on to the term and started using
it to refer to just anything they don't
like about the left they're like oh
that's the regressive left single-payer
health care that's the regressive left
you know performing policing that's the
regressive left so the reason regressive
left is a good analogy here is illiberal
ISM on the left existed for a very long
time at some point the term regressive
left was created and the fact that it
was given a nice sounding name made it
in some people's minds seemed like it
was more prevalent than it actually was
regressive left ISM has been around for
a long time go to the early 20th century
and you see plenty of regressive left
ISM in a number of authoritarian
countries around the world so you put a
catchy name on it and all of a sudden
you've got articles and interviews and
entire shows devoted to exposing the
regressive left the reality was it
always existed I've always called it out
on the show you put a name on it doesn't
really change it that gets us back to
canceled culture is canceled culture a
problem or has it just been given a name
now that is catchy and so a lot of
people are writing about and talking
about canceled culture let me skip the
name they're using for a moment right
cancel culture implies that there is
some widespread culture of canceling
stuff canceling people boycotting you
know whatever the case may be the
reality is this is called boycott
activism that's what if we unload the
term what we're talking about is boycott
activism this is how capitalism in the
marketplace of ideas works advertisers
can advertise on any show they want to
for any reason they can tell us what the
reasons are or not viewers can choose to
buy a product for any reason or choose
not to buy a product for any reason and
if they want to tell the advertiser why
they're doing it they can if they want
to keep their mouth shut and just vote
with their dollars they can do that as
well
advertisers if they start hearing hey
you're advertising with Tucker Carlson
we're not going to buy your stuff the
advertiser is free to listen to those
complaints or to ignore them and the
advertiser is free to say we're gonna
buy more ads with Tucker or we're gonna
cancel our ads with Tucker this is not
coercion this is not oppressive you're
gonna hear some people pop up concern
trolling saying you know when you email
a company and say I will not buy your
stuff if you do X or Y that's coercion
because you're holding them economically
hostage and their employees economic
lives guys come on
it's speech its speech there's no
violence it's a marketplace this is
literally what the free marketeers claim
to want so that's like 98% of boycott
activism which some people call canceled
culture
it's just speech its speech you might
not like but it's speech from people
expressing how they believe others
should spend dollars or spend time on
social media or go or not go to a movie
based on the actors or the producers or
whatever the case may be that's 98
percent okay then you get to the slice
of cancel culture or boycott activism
that can be problematic so there are
instances where maybe somebody said
something wrong offensive discriminatory
twenty years ago and it
comes out now and in comes an angry mob
and says fire them cancel them where I
come down on that slice is let's just be
smart instead of stupid let's use our
judgment if someone said something
stupid at some point and it now came out
and they've apologized and they don't
stand by it and it's a credible apology
and we believe based on their public
facing persona that the thing they said
20 years ago is not representative of
what they believe today then why would
we go and try to get them canceled so to
speak there's no hard and fast rule here
right when Justin Trudeau was uncovered
in blackface in a facebook a school of
yearbook rather not a facebook a school
yearbook from 30 years ago
he apologized he said it was wrong to do
it that it was immature his modern
platform in Canada as a politician
speaks for itself and it has nothing to
do with somebody who believes blackface
is OK
so he did a dumb thing and he took
responsibility why would we go and try
to cancel Justin Trudeau contrast that
with year after year after year of
tucker carlson kowtow into xenophobes
throwing out white supremacist red meats
immigrants make the country dirtier and
you know i can't give you all the
examples so there it makes sense to me
oh this is a concerted this is a
distinguishable pattern I can see why
people would want to target his
advertisers and say we won't do business
with you if you do business with this
guy now let me deal with just one last
part of this we've we've dealt with like
98 percent and then like another one and
a half we've got like the tiniest sliver
left the anti cancel culture crowd will
often insist people's careers are being
unfairly destroyed at the drop of a
tweet so to speak on a whim because they
said something not politically correct
or not in line with the current
orthodoxy or whatever the issue might be
this just rarely happens I mean that's
the reality Trump is accused of dozens
of sexual assaults he said he grabs them
by the you know what he became president
of the
knighted States louis c.k after having
an incident of I believe it was
masturbating in front of someone has a
new project and is doing fine
serial accused domestic assault or and
musical artist Chris Brown continues to
have a great career
if canceled culture were really so
pervasive and so endemic to the modern
milieu so to speak you would have way
more people whose careers have been
ruined by people tweeting about them or
calling their employer or whatever the
case may be now I know some of you will
say yeah but David what about you know
some someone I've never heard of I don't
deny that in a country of 330 million
people you were going to have examples
of everything when we point out look at
all these guns that are being misused
the gun crowd says well when I have ban
guns or really do much of anything
because of these few isolated incidents
we have the Second Amendment in this
country well likewise just because you
can find someone who was unfairly
damaged by a social media shaming
campaign or whatever I may well be on
your side on individual instances of
this but we have this thing called free
speech boycotts are a part of of liberal
democracies and they have been for a
very long time and there is no rash of
every tons of people having their
careers ruined because of some off-color
comment they made decades and decades
ago or even more recently you can find
examples but if this were actually
pervasive the way these people want us
to believe you would have way more
stories of that canceled culture is a
term much like regressive left that is
often used to dismiss people who are
speaking their minds it reminds is the
last thing I'll say on this Trump
derangement syndrome okay Trump
derangement syndrome is a similar term
used in online circles to dismiss
criticisms of Donald Trump as just
that's irrational you have you're
suffering from Trump derangement
syndrome it's a way to dismiss the
actual claims being made
in the same way cancel culture is mostly
a term used to dismiss activism as just
a concerted effort to ruin people's
careers for not being politically
correct so lets you and I together look
at specific examples of bad things let's
call them out and let's move on rather
than going down the same rabbit hole we
went down with the entire regressive
left situation I'm ready to hear from
you about this we'll continue covering
it on the show's Instagram page at david
pakman show follow me on instagram at
david pakman for the latest on my very
safe socially distanced in-state
vacation here in Martha's Vineyard